[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission consacrée
à une association formidable que
j'aimerais vous faire découvrir si vous
ne la connaissez pas déjà qui s'appelle
Messina et chirurgicale et à
l'initiative de deux mers le maire de
Villepreux le maire de Port-Marly pour
sauver deux enfants on va parler de tout
ça avec Francine lecab bonjour Patrice
vous êtes la fondatrice de de mécénat et
chirurgie cardiaque je suis très très
heureux de vous accueillir très heureux
tous c'est aussi le bonjour je veux
directeur général de cette association
mais c'est une chirurgie cardiaque alors
on va parler de l'histoire de cette
association et de son rôle dans quelques
instants et puis des deux mères dont je
parlais à l'instant donc Jean-Baptiste
amonique bonjour vous êtes le maire de
janvier et Cédric bammarine vous êtes le
maire de Port-Marly et alors vous êtes
battus
personnellement on va voir ça tout à
l'heure pour sauver deux enfants c'est
ça oui tout à fait et là on peut on peut
on peut donner le résultat ça y est vous
avez vous avez récolté les fonds pour
permettre de les sauver
on est très fier de vous annoncer ce
matin que l'objectif est atteint et donc
nous avons réussi à collecter ces 24000
euros alors pas uniquement sur la seule
opération du half marathon des femmes on
va parler de tout ce que vous avez fait
parce que vous êtes engagés on y sera
plusieurs mois
ça y est vous pouvez sauver des enfants
on parlera aussi de la façon de sauver
c'est à dire qu'il faut aussi des
familles d'accueil pour les accueillir
c'est très important mais d'abord on va
commencer par présenter cette
association qui s'appelle donc mécénat
et chirurgie cardiaque
[Musique]
parce que
vous avez un parcours absolument
extraordinaire vous êtes la première
femme chirurgien cardiaque en France
c'est ça
pédiatrique pédiatrique
c'est pas important c'est pas important
parce que vous êtes modeste donc vous
êtes vous êtes prof comment vous êtes
venu justement à la chirurgie cardiaque
parce qu'on dit que c'est c'est un
métier où il faut être très costaud
et très délicat faut pas être costaud
non non c'est pas une chose
oui c'est c'est fatiguant ce sens que ce
sont des interventions longues mais faut
surtout pas être costaud faut surtout
être bien soigneux et puis bien avoir
réfléchi à l'avance à ce qu'on va faire
c'est ça c'est pas un métier physique on
va dire mais c'est un métier où ça peut
durer effectivement des heures qu'est-ce
qui vous a intérêt dans cette spécialité
là écoutez moi j'ai voulu faire médecine
pour faire de la chirurgie donc vous
voyez au départ je savais exactement ce
que je voulais et ensuite j'ai découvert
en première année d'internat j'ai fait
un stage en chirurgie cardiaque et j'ai
dit immédiatement c'est ça que je ferais
parce que j'ai trouvé et je tous
toujours aujourd'hui que c'est une
chirurgie miracle j'ai vu un coeur
s'arrêter un cœur ouvert un cœur réparé
et un cœur qui se remet à battre après
plusieurs plusieurs heures
j'ai dit ça c'est magique donc voilà ça
me plaît donc je voulais faire de la
chirurgie cardiaque et ensuite très vite
monsieur orienter vers la chirurgie
cardiaque pédiatrique parce que c'est
une chirurgie de réparation c'est-à-dire
c'est des cœurs qui sont mal formés à la
naissance et que l'on va on va remettre
je dis toujours c'est un peu Lego on
remet les pièces en place voilà donc ça
me plaisait beaucoup c'est très
particulier par rapport à la rien à voir
avec la chirurgie cardiaque adulte en ce
sens que l'adulte il a des lésions
d'usure entre guillemets alors que
l'enfant inné avec sa formation c'est le
cœur qui au départ a été mal formé et
alors vous êtes aperçu évidemment que il
y avait des enfants dans des pays comme
le nôtre qui pouvait être opérés
et puis il y avait des enfants dans des
pays où la médecine et moins avancée si
je peux dire enfin et donc qui il y
avait une inégalité terrible c'est à
dire qu'il y avait des enfants qui
mouraient alors qu'ils auraient pu être
opérés c'est ça mais oui comme je vous
le disais c'est une chirurgie miracle
entre guillemets en ce sens que un
enfant très malade vous le mettez deux
trois quatre heures sur une table
d'opération il va renaître véritablement
à la vie parce qu'on a réparé la pompe
on a réparé le moteur tout simplement et
donc c'est une chose qu'en France nous
savons bien faire qui coûte cher je
tiens quand même toujours à le préciser
parce que je crois que nous nous rendons
pas compte de France de la chance que
nous avons et du coup que ça une
intervention de chirurgie cardiaque
c'est entre 40 et 50 000 euros un cas
moyen vous rendez compte c'est
considérable personne ne sait ça
personne oui parce que personne ne le
paye vraiment parce que nous ne payons
pas moi vous savez j'aime cette phrase
je dis toujours on arrive à l'hôpital
avec la carte verte et pas avec carte
bleue je tiens quand même à faire le
soulier mais je le souligne parce que
j'y tiens fondamentalement moi qui vois
la misère qui se passe dans beaucoup de
pays à travers le monde où les gens
meurent parce que ils ont 10 euros pour
par mois pour vivre dans leur poche
comment voulez-vous faire opérer un
enfant du cœur c'est strictement
impossible il y a pas la sécurité
sociale il y a rien donc il y a rien
alors je me suis dit on sait faire il
faut trouver de l'argent mais ça
l'argent on en trouve
ils ont sur les témoins les gens sont
générés
parce que moi je trouve l'humanité avec
tout le mauvais côté qu'on voit d'un
côté il y a aussi tous les très bons
côtés qu'on voit et ce soir enfin je
sais pas si c'est ce soir ou ce matin
dans la journée
on va parler que des belles choses de la
vie ça va nous changer un petit peu de
la générosité des mécènes de la
générosité des familles d'accueil qui
fait que on peut faire tourner cette
association
en ce moment on opère environ
350 enfants par an 350
ah oui voilà et donc vous en êtes là on
y est on y est on y est formidable et
alors donc l'association est né en 96
comment l'idée voilà l'idée que vous
créez cette association c'est en effet
ça c'est de venir en aide aux enfants de
pays où la chirurgie et voilà les
enfants
ils sont dans des familles d'accueil ils
viennent sans leurs parents dans des
familles d'accueil ils sont opérés dans
une dizaine d'hôpitaux
essentiellement en France mais on
commence aussi à opérer un petit peu
hors des frontières
l'association prend bien sûr tout en
charge et au bout d'environ un mois et
demi deux mois quand tout se passe bien
il rep chez eux transformés guéri ils
vont à l'école on s'occupe ensuite de
leur scolarité et voilà c'est quand ça a
été créé
en 2022 vous dites voilà ou à peu près
365 60 70 enfants par chaque année
au début ça a été est-ce que vous avez
appris des choses bien sûr dans le
fonctionnement de l'association bien sûr
bien sûr parce que c'est pas évident
quoi de tout dans la vie c'est un pas
devant l'autre c'est que la vie si je
fais un pas puis j'en fais un second et
puis un troisième etc c'est la même
chose on a commencé avec deux enfants
qui sont arrivés de Moldavie vous voyez
c'est très symbolique les tous premiers
qui étaient accueillis dans une famille
d'accueil qui était les parents d'un
enfant que j'avais opéré voyez on a
commencé vraiment
et puis petit à petit mais la quantité
n'a jamais jamais primé sur la qualité
des soins en ce sens que ce sont des
dossiers qui sont étudiés de très près
des services hospitaliers en France nous
avons une très bonne qualité de
chirurgie cardiaque pédiatrique donc des
enfants confiés à des services de très
bonnes qualités
un suivi
très important d'ailleurs on les suit
tout au long de leur vie il y a des
enfants ça fait 26 ans que messena
existe on a encore des nouvelles des
premiers opérés oui les petits moldaves
en question
c'est bien sûr de les opérer de les
guérir de les suivre de les suivre et
c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est des
enfants dont vous avez
cardiaque à sauver la vie quoi quand ils
étaient et qui sont là qui ont une vie
absolument normale on en reparlera tout
à l'heure avec les familles d'accueil
il y a aussi alors évidemment de la
guerre c'est c'est l'argent
aussi un peu et la communication et vous
avez très vite
je trouvais extrêmement fort en
communication pour faire connaître
l'association et surtout pour récolter
des fonds oui mais c'est vrai qu'on a on
a aussi une chance c'est qu'on a une fin
heureuse dans notre histoire c'est à
dire c'est des enfants qui démarrent mal
l'histoire des mars mal et puis à la fin
le se termine généralement très très
bien puisque l'enfant est guéri voilà
donc on est toujours parti de l'idée de
dire qu'il fallait partager ce moment de
bonheur d'avoir sauvé un enfant et dans
toute notre communication on parlera
jamais d'un enfant malade mais toujours
d'un enfant guéri parce que le bonheur
et la chance il faut la partager c'est
ce qu'on fait avec ses enfants et puis
après on a rencontré la communication et
le développement c'était toujours fait
avec des rencontres on rencontre des
gens généralement on voit le bon côté
des gens alors on a une chance dans ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on compaque des gens
chouettes on rencontre toujours le choix
de côté des gens
et là on a eu deux mers
ça a pris 15 secondes
c'est un peu comme ça on sauve un enfant
allez on sauve un enfant une fois qu'on
l'a dit on le fait voilà et puis après
ben il y a de toute façon tout ce qu'on
fera ne sera que rien par rapport à ce
que peuvent vivre ces enfants donc si on
commence à dire ah ça va être un petit
peu difficile ça reste de toute façon
plus facile que le reste et puis c'est
vrai que l'association s'est développée
petit à petit et alors vous êtes associé
beaucoup de gros événements sportifs là
vous étiez je crois au départ de la
course du rhum vous étiez aussi
la chance d'aller voir ça de près avec
un départ différé dont on commence à
écouter mais en tout cas
est-ce que c'est pas vous qui est porté
la poisse sur le mauvais temps
du semi-marathon et
c'est vrai que vous avez vous avez
souffert du nouveau temps et la course
du rhum aussi était emporté à cause de
la tempête mais c'est vrai que vous êtes
toujours associé il y a il y a la course
du rhum mais il y a le Tour de France il
y a l'équipe de France de foot 24 Heures
du Mans il y a pas mal d'événements dans
lequel vous êtes quoi le marathon
absolument entendre Paris
c'est des événements
oui c'est des événements qui sont
sympathiques c'est toujours un moment
chouette en fait voilà nous vraiment
c'est cette chance alors on n'a pas été
dans le sport vis-à-vis du souffle du
cœur des enfants on a été là-dedans
parce que ben ça nous a plu on a
rencontré des gens sympas c'est un petit
c'est un petit monde on était ensemble à
la course du rhum et puis finalement on
retrouve à peu près toujours les mêmes
acteurs de ce milieu et puis ben on aime
ça il faut aussi faire ce qu'on aime il
faut pas toujours non plus que réfléchir
il faut c'est gros événements sportifs
enfin ça permet quoi à l'association de
se faire connaître mais ça permet aussi
de de d'obtenir des défauts oui moi je
pense que ça permet surtout la première
chose c'est ça permet de montrer que
l'association est dynamique puisque
notre association elle a une spécificité
d'autres leçons aussi c'est son
dynamisme c'est-à-dire on n'a pas de
subvention on est obligé de trouver des
de l'argent des solutions pour les
enfants et donc on est toujours en
mouvement toujours dynamique et il se
trouve que souvent extrêmement souvent
nos donateurs nous disent vous êtes tout
le temps en train de faire quelque chose
on a envie de de vous aider et de
rentrer là-dedans donc les événements
sportifs ça permet évidemment de lever
beaucoup d'argent ça permet d'avoir une
bonne image mais ça permet de démontrer
qu'on n'est pas une association qui
assise sur son tabouret mais que on se
donne du mal il faut se donner beaucoup
de mal parce que être partenaire de ces
associations il faut il faut mouiller le
maillot c'est le cas de le dire mais je
pense que je pense que ce qui ce qui
nous soutiennent enfin ils vont en
parler c'est de se dire
c'est une petite association familiale
quand même ça reste mais on a la patate
on se donne beaucoup de mal et on a
envie de on a envie de se dire bah on va
s'accrocher à cette chaîne de solidarité
qui bouge qui bouge qui bouge enfin
c'est pas moi qui vous a parlé la force
de et puis la volonté de français
non non voilà mais c'est vrai il rentre
pas assez d'argent
aujourd'hui on a pas le droit de frapper
les enfants mais moi j'en ai rien à
faire
en général
beaucoup d'enfants donc je suis obligé
c'est comme les deux pédaliers d'un vélo
quoi on se motive non voilà je pense
qu'on a de la chance on a beaucoup de
chance il faut la partager et les
événements sportifs c'est un moment de
partage c'est un moment d'action c'est
vraiment il y a des belles histoires et
je trouve que ça correspond à en tous
les cas ce qu'on veut faire c'est à dire
pas parler de la misère du monde mais de
parler de la chance qu'on peut avoir à
notre petit niveau d'aider le devant
et Cédric et Jean-Baptiste c'est vrai
alors Jean-Baptiste vous avez rencontré
Francine justement sur le Tour de France
ouais effectivement
de façon
trottoir non ils sont évident ils sont
sur le Tour de France et on a la chance
à Villepreux d'accueillir le passage du
Tour depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant et dans le village au moment
du passage de la caravane il y a cette
voiture mais c'est là chirurgicardiaque
qui se met un petit peu sur le côté
alors mon premier réflexe en tant que
mère avec les élus et la police
municipale qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
sont en train de sortir du tracé prévu
par les par les autorités et puis
finalement ils étaient pas loin de chez
eux puis c'est là qu'on s'est rencontré
que Francine m'a dit qu'elle qu'elle
habitait Villepreux et j'ai fait le
rapprochement on a fait le rapprochement
avec l'association et on se dit il faut
qu'on se revoit et comme le disait Orso
quand on s'est revu sans mauvais jeu de
mots ça a quand même été un coup de cœur
et en 15 secondes on a décidé non pas
d'aller sauver un seul enfant avec une
ville mais deux enfants avec qui sont
formidables
c'est vrai que je comprends qu'on ait
envie de se battre alors d'abord pour
cette cause qui est qui est merveilleuse
c'est-à-dire sauver des enfants et parce
que vous a soufflé
et vous Francine voilà une
volonté une quelque chose de formidable
quoi
ils ont vraiment mais c'est ça en
vacances on va pas se renvoyer
l'abonnement parce que légitimement
de dire des vrais choses des bonnes
choses parce que vraiment ils ont une
formidable humilité parce qu'on ne voit
que la manière mon petit présente
l'association une petite association
formidable finalement ce qu'on fait
c'est pas grand chose en fait ce qu'ils
font c'est énorme c'est énorme on
constate en participant aux différents
événements on voit mais c'est non on
voit des acteurs mobilisés pour cette
cause là un peu partout et c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve systématiquement un petit
noyau un peu un peu les mêmes et on
comprend assez aisément pourquoi on a
envie de s'engager pour ça parce qu'il
partage leur énergie Francine une
énergie formidable et vraiment dès le
premier contact moi j'ai rencontré par
l'intermédiaire de JB et dès le premier
contact il y ait une lumière il y a un
truc assez exceptionnel et Dorson on
peut dire on peut dire exactement la
même chose le directeur général c'est
non c'est ce qu'on fait c'est pas
compliqué mais si parce qu'en fait si on
parvenait à faire le quart de ce que
vous faites mais on serait on serait on
serait heureux qu'on va venir te donner
un petit coup de main
vous avez encore un peu de temps un jour
rêver et ça c'est pas je dis pas ça en
l'air il le savent parce que je le pense
profondément j'aurais adoré être mère et
je réponds à Francine que ce n'est pas
trop tard
parce que je trouve c'est une fonction
absolument magnifique pourquoi parce que
on s'occupe on est au proche des gens on
fait tout pour aider les gens c'est très
multiforme enfin je vais pas vanter
votre profession mais ça va de ramassage
des des encombrants dont on parlait tout
à l'heure jusqu'au réunions jusque c'est
un des aspects magnifiques de la
politique
on dit souvent ça mais donc c'est vrai
que c'est ceux qui sont au contact avec
la population qui voit aussi le résultat
de le résultat de ce qu'il faut quoi ce
qu'on voit clairement parler ça mais au
tout vous êtes votre père était le maire
de Sano ouais il était merde donc vous
connaissez bien
une belle fonction une très belle
fonction Edward des jeunes comme ça
c'est très sympa c'est c'est très sympa
quand on regarde des sondages
alors souvent la classe politique est
très critiquée mais le maire reste
encore surnage encore c'est c'est encore
le c'est la fonction prévu
alors évidemment forcément
ça donne envie sur la chirurgie
cardiaque justement dans les pays alors
qu'ils sont moins développés que les
autres est-ce que ça fait des progrès
est-ce que est-ce que vous espérez aussi
qu'un jour il y aura peut-être moins
besoin de d'amener des enfants ici pour
les pour les opérer mais regardez
Coluche quand il a créé son
ses restos du cœur
il a dit c'est pour quelques années mais
voilà ma réponse
c'est à dire bon mécénat exactement 26
ans maintenant
j'ai vu des progrès j'ai vu des progrès
en ce qui concerne la connaissance des
malformations et le diagnostic parce
qu'avant d'opérer c'est un diagnostic
délicat diagnostic précis et là il y a
eu un réel progrès
mais la chirurgie reste encore
un petit peu à la traîne pour
essentiellement pour des raisons
d'argent voilà c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est
politique dans un pays c'est quand même
on dit j'aime pas la politique mais
c'est quand même la politique et nous
gouverne tant qu'on donnera pas
suffisamment d'argent les hôpitaux sont
alors il y a des étrangers je parle de
l'Afrique puisque beaucoup de nos
enfants
c'est vrai qu'il y a qui des Chinois qui
même des Francs des Français enfin tout
le monde vient construire des hôpitaux
mais l'hôpital c'est une coquille vide
l'important moi je dis toujours jamais
être opéré par un bon chirurgien sous
une tente que par un naze dans un palais
en marbre voilà donc il faut la
formation des gens pour ça il faut que
les gens soient payés il faut enfin je
veux dire on y est pas alors pour
répondre à votre question ça viendra
bien sûr que ça
en 26 ans moi je vois le problème depuis
26 ans on a beaucoup progressé au point
de vue qualité du diagnostic
suivi des malades etc mais pas encore
beaucoup un petit peu mais pas beaucoup
au niveau chirurgical le goût d'une
opération d'un enfant c'est la vous
disiez 24000 euros pour les pour les
deux c'est ça oui c'est à peu près 12000
euros
il faut bien le dire c'est quand même
des conventions que les directeurs des
hôpitaux français ont bien voulu nous
accorder
pour les remercier parce que pour
beaucoup d'hôpitaux c'est un entre
guillemets un peu un manque à gagner
mais ils ont accepté de jouer le jeu
avec nous et donc de nous faire ce qu'on
appelle des forfaits parce que le plus
dramatique quand vous opérez un enfant
ça peut durer trois jours mais il peut y
avoir des complications et ça peut durer
un mois donc si on n'est pas dans un
forfait c'est mortel au point de vue
financier et quand annonce les 12000
euros ce sont des forfaits hospitaliers
qui nous sont accordés et encore une
fois je remercie les directeurs des
hôpitaux
mais à la sécurité sociale ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est 30-45 ans
vous avez une dizaine de personnes
on dit toujours ce qui coûte cher c'est
le matériel c'est pas le matériel c'est
l'humain 70% des frais hospitaliers
c'est les hommes et les femmes c'est les
humains
mais grâce aux accords que vous avez pu
passer voilà avec
24000 euros
[Musique]
notre cheval de bataille c'est de former
les gens c'est pas d'aller opérer là-bas
parce que tous les enfants sont pas
opérés mais tous les enfants sont à
soigner et la première contact c'est le
diagnostic avec le médecin qui s'il est
à même s'il a une bonne formation plutôt
que d'envoyer l'enfant faire 2000 km
pour aller voir un cardio pédiatre alors
qu'il y avait pas besoin c'est des coûts
pour les parents c'est très compliqué
donc notre partie prix on a un très très
gros programme de formation on a formé
plus de 700 médecins aujourd'hui qu'on
suit qu'on suit en ligne d'être au plus
près des enfants de faire d'abord un
premier diagnostic qui soit bon et puis
après de le rentrer dans un parcours de
soins qui soit tracé mais il faut pas
commencer le parcours de soins par la
fin il faut le commencer par le début et
le début c'est vous êtes dans un petit
village il y a un médecin qui a pas
forcément d'électricité mais on a mis
des outils on a mis une formation qui va
lui permettre de pas se tromper puis de
l'envoyer à bon escient chez un autre
médecin qui va pas se tromper qui va
médecin et un jour peut-être qu'il
arrivera jusqu'à nous et on le prendra
en charge donc on a plus à gagner à pour
ses enfants à être le plus près de la
formation du premier contact que d'aller
construire un hôpital dans lequel on a
la moitié des enfants qui vont venir qui
aurait pas dû venir parce que l'hôpital
quand vous devez vous taper 17 heures de
bus pour venir 3 jours et trouver un
hébergement c'est-à-dire c'est pour ces
familles ils vendent tout pour ça donc
on a besoin d'être au plus près d'eux il
faut pas réfléchir comme des Européens
qui pensent que non non il faut
réfléchir terrain il faut le
bénéficiaire c'est l'enfant il faut
partir de l'enfant faut pas partir du
enfin on a beaucoup formé en forme
beaucoup comment vous êtes alerté sur
les sur les cas des enfants qui qui
doivent être opérés essentiellement par
les médecins locaux
au fil des années on a qu'on a connu
qu'on a comme le dit Orso qu'on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'enseignements en
allant sur place en mission des missions
de d'enseignement on a créé depuis un
certain nombre d'années un enseignement
à distance
qui s'appelle le 5/5 on a trouvé ce nom
très amusant je vous reçois fort et bien
vous avez le 5/5 et
donc ce sont essentiellement eux
maintenant qui nous envoie les dossiers
d'accord et donc il vous alerte alors il
nous envoie un dossier on redemande des
compléments d'examens on essaye de les
faire progresser aussi maintenant dans
la plupart des capitales on peut avoir
des scanners donc ça nous permet de leur
demander des scanners éventuellement on
les paye ici non pas les si les parents
n'ont pas les moyens pour étudier dans
certaines pathologies il faut absolument
voir la la voie pulmonaire pour voir si
on peut réparer ou pas réparer
enfin je vous cite cet exemple mais il y
en a plein comme ça donc c'est qualité
des dossiers qui sont envoyés qui
s'améliorent incontestablement d'année
en année nos correspondants locaux ont
le ça on le voit on voit le progrès on
voit l'évolution et on reçoit des
dossiers bien ficelés qu'on étudie on
dit bon ben oui à 80 19 % c'est le bon
diagnostic donc on prend l'enfant avec
telle ou tel degré d'urgence on va
l'envoyer à tel ou tel endroit et puis
on le présente au famille d'accueil
parce que je pense qu'on va en parler
c'est tellement important il faut bien
savoir que la France qu'on critique
toujours la France mais la France a une
image incroyable en termes de
humanitaire qualité
non intérêt nom de profitent c'est à
dire on construit pas des hôpitaux parce
que on veut vendre nos produits
les gens sur le pays vous savez ils le
savent ils savent que les Français ont
vraiment cette culture cette expertise
c'est pas au rabais c'est à dire ils
vont avoir le ce qui est mieux et à un
moment il faut quand même se envoyer des
cocorico parce que en critique on
critique toujours une image qui est pas
si mauvaise que ça c'est un excellent
c'est fou en fait
sur ce volume
évidemment
on va parler de ça parce que c'était
essentiel et cette de point sur lequel
vous travaillez beaucoup vous aussi
aujourd'hui c'est le sont les familles
d'accueil
alors certains sujets parce que en effet
on a expliqué comment voilà les enfants
les deux si vous parviennent vous faites
venir
les enfants en France et il faut en
effet des familles pour les accueillir
parce que ça va durer entre quoi un mois
et demi à peu près alors Patrice vous
fait le trajet très rapidement on reçoit
le dossier on dit ok on va le prendre
dans trois mois quatre mois cinq mois
faut organiser évidemment les
autorisations les papiers et tout ça ça
prend du temps et je tiens absolument
évidemment à citer nos amis d'aviation
sans frontières c'est une association
fantastique avec laquelle on travaille
depuis le premier jour et ceux qui vont
transporter les enfants c'est à dire ils
vont sur place ils prennent le petit
Intel à Douala ou ou
Bamako il le ramène si l'enfant est dans
un état précaire c'est un voyage médic
réaliser avec oxygène avec souvent des
infirmières et il le ramène soit à Paris
soit directement dans les villes de
province où sont opérés les enfants
d'accord l'enfant vient sans sa famille
oui on va pas développer mais on peut
comprendre facilement que c'est
ingérable de pour nous d'accueillir les
familles et en plus les enfants sont
beaucoup plus sages sans leur famille et
puis les parents ont deux enfants
donc ils arrivent ils sont accueillis
par les fameuses familles d'accueil dont
on va tous parler parce que moi j'en ai
plein la bouche c'est des gens
exceptionnels mais c'est une charge très
lourde c'est-à-dire pendant un mois et
demi deux mois ces familles vont
accueillir cet enfant qui est un enfant
malade avec tous les déplacements à
l'hôpital pour les consultations les
interventions etc la charge émotionnelle
la séparation au bout d'un mois et demi
quand l'enfant va repartir donc c'est
une lourde charge que ces gens
extraordinaires acceptent de façon
merveilleuse et je peux vous assurer que
les enfants qui viennent sont heureux
comme c'est pas possible dans leur
famille d'accueil alors justement j'ai
rencontré hier une famille d'accueil qui
est qui est gamber c'est Catherine et
Gilles Blanchard ils ont accueilli 6
enfants depuis le début et ils vont
accueillir bientôt ré-accueillir un
enfant qui est opéré quand il est fait 3
ans et puis évidemment quand les enfants
grandissent c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas que ça s'est mal passé mais c'est il
faut changer certains cas pas fréquent
signaler quand même mais dans certains
cas il y a nécessité d'une réopération
effectivement il va réaccueillir cette
info qui avait trois ans la première
fois il a 10 ans aujourd'hui donc ils
ont très heureux et alors j'ai fait une
émission avec eux qu'on pourra voir dans
quelques dans quelques jours il raconte
en effet
le premier contact c'est pas forcément
facile quand dans les trois quatre
premiers jours il faut parce que les
enfants évidemment ils arrivent dans un
monde qui ne connaissent pas d'une
famille ceux qui ne connaissent pas et
puis et puis peu à peu le lien se fait
enfin et devient absolument formidable
et on va regarder juste un petit extrait
là où ils disent il parle de du moment
où il les ramène c'est fini il les
ramène à l'aéroport
oui pourtant ça pas duré si longtemps
mais il y a un attachement qui s'est
créé et quand il repart on les ramène à
l'aéroport il repartent avec leurs
parents ils font comme ça on reprend
notre voiture on se parle plus et on
pleure
c'est
étonnant c'est étonnant surtout les
premiers enfants après
on dit
s'habitue en disant allez c'est bon
c'est pas nous
[Rires]
les premières Aïcha
on se parle plus la somme d'émotion
cette troisième activité
ce week-end sur la Route du Rhum à
Saint-Malo il y avait une famille
d'accueil qui était là avec ce jeune
Malien dont j'ai oublié le prénom
tu es là pour le baptême du du bateau on
a vu cette famille d'accueil totalement
engagée mobilisé et puis finalement très
heureuse de faire ce qu'ils font avec ce
même sourire et le plus formidable c'est
de voir le sourire du petit quoi le
petit mais alors eux ils font un truc
très mignon c'était il faut un petit un
petit livre de photos qui donne à
l'enfour quand il repart et c'est vrai
qu'on voit on voit l'évolution
c'est-à-dire que le moment il arrive et
c'est vrai que et ce que vous dites
souvent d'ailleurs
et c'est le réflexe de tous les parents
quand les enfants commencent à bien
manger avoir reprendre l'appétit tout ça
ça y est on disait c'est bon quoi bien
sûr bien sûr c'est les enfants qui sont
heureux dans leur famille d'accueil
alors il faut savoir alors vous avez
raison de le dire c'est c'est un
investissement de temps à énorme parce
qu'il faut l'amener il faut l'amener au
consultation à l'hôpital etc enfin parce
que les enfants sont suivis évidemment
d'abord avant l'opération et des examens
il y a l'opération et il y a le poste
opératoire donc voilà il faut savoir que
c'est du temps mais quand on voit le
bonheur de de ces gens là on se dit
c'est formidable quoi
c'est difficile à trouver les familles
bah écoutez
comment vous dire avec vous Patrice ça
va devenir facile
non mais j'espère mais il faut il faut
faire un appel parce que voilà on est on
est beaucoup là pour ça aussi faut faire
un appel devenez famille d'accueil et
des nous accueillir des enfants parce
qu'évidemment messena on ne perd
doucement mais lentement chaque fois un
petit peu plus d'enfants un petit peu
plus d'enfants on augmente notre courbe
et les croissante dieu soit loué pas
trop mais un petit peu il faut
renouveler les familles les familles qui
ont beaucoup accueilli des gens qui ont
des problèmes
à l'intérieur de leur famille qui ne
peuvent pas accueillir donc il faut un
renouvellement permanent et donc oui
nous avons besoin de famille d'accueil
en clair oui mais je pense enfin il faut
vraiment aider les gens il y a on sait
qu'il y a plein de gens qui ont envie de
le faire
ils hésitent un petit peu et ses
émissions nous permettent de vraiment
d'aller leur dire passer le cap et
surtout qui sachent que chez mécénats
vous avez vu c'est une petite
association familiale qu'on le veuille
non mais dans l'état d'esprit surtout
parce que après petite association on
fait équipe avec eux sa direction jamais
seul on est tout le temps là on est à
leur côté ceux qui vont accueillir en
toute liberté c'est à dire on n'est pas
là pour vérifier si les pâtes étaient
bien cuites comme ça mais on est il y a
tout le temps 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 il y a toujours un traducteur si
l'enfant parle pas la langue on est à
côté parce que ces enfants c'est nos
enfants on est ensemble dans la même
chaîne il faut pas que les gens aient
peur en disant je vais pas y arriver
bien sûr qu'il y a un moment qui est
difficile la séparation moi j'ai été
famille d'accueil aussi donc je sais ce
que c'est bah effectivement la route de
Roissy elle est longue mais c'est des
souvenirs c'est tellement fantastique
que les gens se disent allez si ils nous
écoutent aujourd'hui si ça j'ai toujours
voulu faire bah faites-le on est là avec
vous on sera à vos côtés on vous aidera
on vous aigu vous laissera la liberté de
profiter comme vous avez fait avec vos
enfants enfin quand on a des enfants au
début on n'a pas le mode d'emploi il
n'arrive pas avec un mode d'emploi là
c'est pareil mais on fait équipe on
ouvre vraiment l'histoire on est une
chaise on fait équipe et ben on était
ensemble je pense que vous avez vu qu'on
est vraiment très très très présent avec
eux parce que
c'est un bien commun les enfants donc
voilà c'est c'est l'émission nous
permettent de le dire des gens qui
regardent devenir famille d'accueil
c'est simple d'aller sur le site c'est
super
et de prendre contact et voilà et puis
de discuter et puis après on discute ils
ont envie tout de suite ils ont envie
plus tard ils ont encore des freins ils
ont oui c'est pas forcément pour les
pour le mois qui vient j'étais avec une
personne
j'étais avec une personne qui m'a dit ah
je pense que c'est bon c'est décidé ça
sera au mois de juin parce qu'elle avait
un problème avec sa sœur elle devait
trouver une solution qui avait des
petits problèmes
mais il faut franchir c'est il faut
franchir ce pas c'est comme quand on
décide de faire le Half Marathon des
Sables on peut regarder les plaquettes
toute sa vie puis un moment il faut
mettre les chaussures
et puis une fois qu'on est parti quand
vous êtes partis vous êtes des je pense
que premier kilomètre vous êtes dit non
de dieu il est encore temps de faire
demi-tour
continue mais on y va et puis et puis on
y va et on est on est des blanches
qui connaissent qui a pris un congé sans
solde pendant quelques mois pour pour
accueillir de plus en plus les gens de
plus en plus jeunes qui veulent pas
attendre la retraite parce que vous
dites souvent Francine les beaux créneau
c'est les jeunes retraités parce qu'ils
ont encore
parce que c'est le bénévole
la première famille en télétravail il
avait trois jours de télétravail sa
femme avait deux jours de travail ils
ont fait la somme ils ont dit ça fait 5
+ le weekend 7 et ça a marché ils ont un
peu comme quoi même dans le télétravail
il y a du
positifs
merci merci à vous et à tv78 parce que
ça nous permet de rappeler Francine et
hors-sol l'importance des familles
d'accueil et nous lancer un appel
également puisque l'idée c'est donc de
sauver deux ans
maintenant il faut et on aimerait
beaucoup avoir une famille d'accueil
dans dans chacune de nos vies il
semblerait que ça soit plutôt pas mal
embarqué du du côté de Port-Marly ce
sera aussi le cas du côté de Villepreux
c'est vrai que trouver une famille
d'accueil ça demande autant d'énergie et
d'implication que d'aller collecter les
fonds
voilà essentiel et ben justement on va
parler de ce que vous avez fait on va
voilà on va parler de cette association
vous avez créé qui s'appelle donc les
élus du cœur exactement
[Musique]
alors votre engagement on a évoqué tout
à l'heure vous avez rencontré aussi de
le cas sur le Tour de France et et enfin
comment vous êtes dit Alain Bastien on
pourrait peut-être le les dés les des
mécénats c'est vrai qu'au début on était
peut-être pas parti sur un projet de de
cette ampleur mais lorsqu'on s'est
rencontré et que Francine et Orso m'ont
présenté l'association comme ils
viennent de le faire dans cette émission
tout de suite je me suis dit il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose ma première
idée c'était de dire j'ai une course
annuelle qui s'appelle la ville
prosienne et donc c'était de reverser
les recettes de la course à
l'association et puis j'ai demandé à
Francine combien il faut pour ce vers un
enfant il dit 12000 euros une petite
course on y sera pas et donc l'idée
c'était d'impliquer la ville à travers
une multitude d'événements des concerts
le cross du collège des choses comme ça
comme j'aime pas faire les choses seul
et que pour le coup là le mieux n'était
pas l'ennemi du bien on s'est dit on
peut peut-être faire deux enfants à
24000 euros j'ai appelé Cédric j'ai dit
est-ce que tu nous suivrais avec
Port-Marly il a tout de suite dit oui et
l'autre étape de la réflexion c'était de
dire si nos villes associations scolaire
entreprise commerçant s'engage dans
cette aventure il faut qu'on puisse
quelque part nous aussi montrer
l'exemple et qu'on mouille le Mali avant
de parler de de vous et de ce que vous
avez fait
comment ça a été cueilli justement par
les habitants de vos villes c'était
super bien accueilli c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui nous a porté
c'est une partie de ce qui nous a porté
jusqu'à la fin c'est redouter un peu
parce que même avant de parler du défi
enfin il fallait organiser des
événements puis organiser à la marche
des événements qu'on avait l'habitude de
mener et finalement ça a tellement mis
un prix que parfois on a encore des
initiatives qui arrivent il y a une
chorale au port mardi le 25 novembre et
il y a des initiatives spontanées de
personnes qui disent mais moi je vais
faire mon événement et je vais le faire
au profit de votre projet il y a eu ça
il y a des commerçants aussi qu'ils ont
aidé
appris il y a trois jours on a le Festi
jeu à Villepreux qui a lieu le week-end
prochain sur une journée ou donc le jeu
est mis en lumière sous toutes ses
formes et là il y aura quelque chose qui
va se faire aussi au profit de
l'association mais cela chirurgie
cardiaque avec les associations
partenaires voilà des choses que nous
n'avons pas impulsé pour le coup mais
qui se passe et au-delà de nos vies je
vois il y a des villes voisines pareil
le PEC même dit m'appelle c'est génial
on va faire un truc pour mécénat
physiquement j'en ai des frissons mais
c'est vrai c'est pas c'est pas de la
blague
je trouve ça formidable
mais tena bon on sauve des enfants mais
on rencontre des gens exceptionnel
c'est vraiment des je trouve que c'est
un des grands plaisirs de la vie sans
contrer des gens bien alors
dans ce que vous avez organisé alors il
y a eu de la course Villepreux
il y a des concerts que vous avez
organisé il y a eu un dîner de gala
plaisir d'être hors-saut était là aussi
et c'est vrai que l'idée de gala il y
avait des il y avait une vente aux
enchères je me souviens et j'ai été
frappé par la générosité des
participants on a fait 99000 euros de
collecte sur ce gars-là
tout confondu avec la vente aux enchères
notamment mais l'ensemble des heures ils
sont partis
de mais au-delà de ça c'était sympa et
c'était sympa
les gens étaient sympas tout le monde
était content d'être là c'est pas mal de
nos jours
parce que nous c'est comme ça à
l'origine ce qu'on cherche donc Cédric
peut vous le dire moi ce qui m'a
vraiment épaté c'est à quelques images
en même temps à quel point cette
initiative a réussi à fédérer très
largement on avait des collègues élus il
y avait des entrepreneurs il y avait des
associatifs il y avait des citoyens sans
qualité sans fonction particulière mais
tout cela pour la même cause et je
remercie encore les pyramides qui
peuvent absolument
et qui ont fait cette c'est vrai que
vous avez raison au-delà de la vente aux
enchères ou de la déforer il y avait une
très bonne ambiance les gens étaient
heureux d'être là et peut-être heureux
d'être là pour pour une bonne cause
aussi
il y a quelque chose humainement qui se
passe dans ces moments-là mais c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être ça le plus
formidable alors on n'oublie pas
le nerf de la guerre c'était il fallait
qu'on récolte quelque chose doutez pas
la générosité humaine des personnes qui
en revanche oui c'est impressionnant
mais ça a été le cas sur ce gars-là
comme ça a été du cas sur la course dont
on parlera après c'est vraiment pour
parler si vous voulez alors
il y a des dînés de gala une fois que le
dessert est fini tout le monde se tient
la pâte et là il fallait presque dire eh
les gars
c'est un indicateur c'est un indicateur
aussi simple que ça et parce que bah
vous êtes chouette et puis vous avez une
idée des gens chouette qui se
ressemblent s'assemblent et puis voilà
et ce qui est super sympa c'est de voir
que un grand chef d'entreprise
va pouvoir faire un don et en restant à
donner mais c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
assez exceptionnel c'est-à-dire que il
aurait pu vouloir une communication nous
on lui a posé la question est-ce que
l'entreprise doit figurer sur les
maillots qui étaient là j'ai une demande
si vous voulez si vous voulez dire
quelques mots ils se reconnaîtra mais je
c'est un voisin je le remercie parce que
à atteindre cet objectif de sauver des
enfants mais en parallèle on a aussi des
parties des personnes des particuliers
et je disais sans qualité qui ont donné
10 20 30 euros et mi bout à vous tout ça
permet de
footballeur les amis de Monsieur le
maireux
et puis
redoutable défenseur central c'est vrai
je suis un temps
et c'est vrai qu'il est ouais c'était
quoi libéraux j'ai joué libéraux j'ai
joué de la terrasse
je vous ai pas vu dans la liste de
ce semi marathon on appelle ça
semi-marathon
voilà des sables alors faut raconter ce
que c'est mais attendez ça là
d'abord comment vous avez eu l'idée
d'aller faire ça je te laisse commencer
sur ce que c'est une expérience de fou
mais dans vraiment dans tous les sens du
terme et humainement c'est une
expérience incroyable alors généralement
les les trucs fou ça vient de JB je le
dis je le redis je le redirai ça vient
de JB c'est petit vous verrez il y a
d'autres idées de fou qui là et donc
c'est c'est vrai qu'il m'appelle il
m'appelle il y a quelques mois de ça
finalement ça a été assez court en
préparation mais ça nous a permis de
tenir pour me proposer de faire et vous
le disiez tout à l'heure de faire un
semi le Half Alf moi j'ai tendance à
traduire en ce moment
j'ai déjà 42 ça devrait aller bon il y a
un peu de conditions
et puis non c'était 120
déjà ce qu'a dit Cédric aventure humaine
avant même d'être sportive aventure
humaine exceptionnelle on a rencontré
des gens de toutes les nationalités de
tous les horizons d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de coureurs de participants
certaines célébrités certains
influenceurs qu'on a retrouvé sur la
Route du Rhum donc ça montre aussi la
fidélité à mécénat mais on a fait des
rencontres qu'on n'aurait jamais pu
faire dans un autre cadre moi je prends
juste une petite anecdote mais j'ai en
mémoire les 10 derniers kilomètres de la
première étape où je me retrouve à
courir avec un type qui s'appelle Marc
un anglais que je ne connaissais pas on
se connaissait pas et puis on avait à
peu près la même cadence on était au
bout de la première étape des 173 bornes
et on s'est dit on court ensemble les 10
derniers pour pouvoir franchir ligne
d'arrivée ensemble et je crois que
depuis ce jour il connaît toute ma vie
je connais toute la sienne c'est assez
amusant
il y avait un grand nombre de
participants qui étaient là aussi pour
des associations et des fois on sait
tous donnés entre entre il y avait des
il y avait des personnes qui étaient là
pour un combat sur la contre la maladie
de Charcot il y avait une une femme
assez exceptionnelle pour un enfant
atteint de maladie aussi donc elle
essaie de collecter des fonds par
exemple
on lui a fait un don et nous a fait
vraiment il y avait de solidarité et sur
la course
qui a été un petit peu perturbé alors
c'est ça parce que vous arrivez en
principe c'était sur quatre jours et
manque de peau il y a la tempête comme
comme sur la Route du Rhum excusez-nous
je pense que là il faut faire gaffe
quand vous allez avec moi et donc c'est
plus quatre jours c'est trois jours
ouais déjà on arrive on est quand même
aux Canaries donc dans les quatre jours
il y avait un jour de repos voilà c'est
pour ça on arrive sur l'île des Canaries
de faire ceintura on s'attend à un peu
de vent mais on s'attend à du soleil on
sort de l'aéroport c'est le déluge il
est d'ailleurs des des images qui le
montrent on se dit qu'on n'est pas aux
Canaries
Cédric commence qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
et finalement on arrive le dimanche on
devait partir le lundi sur une étape d'à
peu près 20 km on devait faire une étape
à peu près 20 km le deuxième journée
n'est à plomb un jour de repos et la
dernière étape on n'a pas pu partir le
lundi alerte rouge sur Lille donc
l'organisation nous réunit en disant on
vous redonne rendez-vous lundi soir pour
savoir si on peut partir demain lundi
soir la bonne nouvelle tombe il y a eu
beaucoup c'était très pesant comme
ambiance on avait hâte finalement de
commencer donc on discutait avec les
participants est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
partir nous on était là aussi pour
mécénat j'avais eu peur de l'annulation
de la course et finalement le mardi
matin on peut partir sauf que le lundi
soir il nous annonce on fait tout sur
trois jours donc pas de journée de repos
et la l'étape longue qui devait être sur
la deuxième journée et ben vous la
commencez tout de suite donc les 63
bornes
comment on fait vous êtes arrivés devant
quel état un pied de Bordeaux un pied
dans l'autre jusqu'au bout
finalement vraiment les 63 km de la
première journée c'est pas il faut une
certaine condition mais on y va et puis
on a l'objectif et puis on pense moi les
premiers kilomètres je vais me raconter
les premiers kilomètres on y va en se
lance et puis on a encore tous les
dossiers les mairies le boulot le boulot
on pense encore à tout ça et puis viens
un moment là on déconnecte et puis on se
rend compte que autour de soi on a on a
des gens il y a des coureurs formidables
qu'on commence à découvrir il y a des
paysages extraordinaires et là on se dit
attends relâche et vas-y tu as ce défi
là et tu y vas et tu vas jusqu'au bout
et voilà on termine en plus ça te permet
parce que vous avez engagé votre père
de famille aussi de ce côté là et il a
moyen à 60 ans c'était l'année de ses 60
ans il les a en juin dernier il m'a
épaté il a fait il a fait il a fait le
feu avec nous il finit alors il y avait
la possibilité de faire 40 sur la
première journée et pas aller jusqu'au
bout des 63 il est parti blessé donc
comme il fallait que il termine les
trois jours c'était l'objectif il s'est
arrêté au 40 sur la première étape
c'est surtout que moi vous ne mettez pas
du tout pour le classement mais mais le
il finit quand même 27e sur 275
sur le format 100 km nous on était sur
le format 120 donc il a vraiment
performé c'est éclaté je crois que si on
lui proposait de repartir mais on a vécu
aussi tous les trois quelque chose
d'assez intense et honnêtement quand on
rentre bon on a mélangé tout de suite
dans les dossiers comme le disait Cédric
on était à la tâche immédiatrice
mais c'était pas facile de s'en remettre
pas physiquement
doit se séparer de l'enfant quand on a
vécu quelque chose de si fort sur une
courte période avec les mêmes personnes
unités de lieu unité de temps unité de
personnes
je sais pas pour toi mais voilà moi il y
a eu un petit pansement au coeur pendant
quelques jours quand même avec un truc
c'est repartir les familles d'accueil
quand il disait
de reprendre un autre mais c'est
quelqu'un qui arrive à 5 6 enfants c'est
vrai c'est la preuve que voilà il se
passe quelque chose de bon très fort
60 km comme ça comme il dit le soir vous
étiez mort comment et bizarrement le
soir tellement chargé d'adrénaline que
qu'on se retrouvait on se retrouvait le
soir à pas pouvoir dormir
on dormait quelques heures quand même
mais vraiment le temps de repos était
très court tellement chargé et tous les
soirs jusqu'au dernier soir que
on a Cédric le disait on a fait une
préparation courte mais néanmoins qui a
été
utile pour nous je pense notamment aux
entraînements avec le sac parce que
fallait quand même ce coltier les 8 à 10
kg par jour même si la partie bivouac a
été un petit peu bouleversée
donc on a on a joué le jeu du camping on
a joué le jeu de manger la nourriture
yophylisée aussi qui vous a été préparé
qu'on avait emmené avec nous surtout
donc on avait tout le tout de de chez
vous donc il avait préparé dans cette
non non en fait on avait une dotation
dans cet élan de générosité parce qu'on
a aussi
à Decathlon c'est une dotation en
paillophilisée
l'enduroshop de Bois-d'Arcy aussi qui
nous qui qui nous a équipé avec Laurent
qui est un type aussi formidable mais
mais voilà il a fallu appréhender le
terrain les passages entre la caillasse
entre le sable il y a un moment où on
n'est pas bien je veux dire quand on
fait la première étape 63 bornes la
course de toute façon sur des distances
aussi longues il y a des passages à vide
faut savoir les surmonter sur partir et
là c'est là c'est formidable il y a
toujours un moment une rencontre une
discussion quelqu'un qui est là pour
nous ramasser au bord de la route et
dire on y va on continue et puis la
personne on va peut-être nous la
recroiser 20 bornes plus tard c'est elle
qui va être en difficulté on va lui
allez vas-y jusqu'au bout ça c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique et si ça
vous aurez aussi rencontrer des gens
bien quoi avec qui on a gardé contact en
plus tout à fait c'est formidable alors
l'étape suivante maintenant bah ça y est
donc les fonds sont récoltés
l'étape on le rappelle c'est la famille
d'accueil c'est les familles d'accueil
il faut il faut il faut trouver
vous les étapes suivantes elles sont
tous les jours
les étapes suivantes c'est tous les
jours chez vous
la famille d'accueil une fois qu'on aura
opéré l'enfant les deux enfants
non mais évidemment
on sera évidemment on serait évidemment
en fin c'est notre souhait et nous à
titre personnel tous les deux nous on
continuera avec mécénat et on va bien
sûr on va pas faire de d'annonces il
peut y avoir des gens qui se battent
parce que il y a des il y a d'autres
élus des chanteurs rouges par contre
j'ai regardé les photos là ils sont
magnifiques
vous allez trouver où votre maillot à
chaque fois qu'on est arrivé sur
lindarius c'était voilà le le comment il
faisait les gars en rouge donc ça
suscité des questions mais les élus du
cœur
on va continuer
auprès de mes Sénat on va faire des
annonces un petit peu plus tard mais on
a déjà un ou deux projets à l'esprit
d'accord qu'on va pouvoir annoncer avec
l'esprit dans les jambes parce que c'est
dans
il y a la main de tirer Henry
le gala et puis d'être notre
cœur mais depuis longtemps avis bon on
va l'emmener sur une prochaine alors
absolument
bravo bravo et merci à tous
[Musique]